I want to talk about lies and
politicians at their first presidential
debate on Monday night in New York City
not New York City outside of New York
City in Hempstead New York Donald Trump
made 34 false claims some people call
these lies Hillary Clinton made six
false claims some people call those lies
also a lie is not a lie is not a lie in
the sense that there are different
degrees of Lies and I'm going to get
into that in a second let's start first
with the list this is just a sampling we
don't have time to go through all of 34
lies told by Donald Trump I'll show you
a sampling first here uh at the debate
on Monday Donald Trump said that a judge
had not ruled New York City
stop-and-frisk unconstitutional that was
not true Donald Trump claimed that he
had only had four business bankruptcies
that's not true the number six is
Hillary Clinton stated Trump claimed
that he never said pregnancy was
inconvenient to employers that's not
true he did say that Donald Trump denied
saying climate change was a hoax well
that's widely on record he said it many
times Donald Trump denied having
expressed support for the invasion of
Iraq untrue I played that audio for you
from the howard stern show of many many
times Donald Trump claimed that Hillary
Clinton has been fighting Isis her
entire adult life of course that's not
true Donald Trump claim that New York
City murders are up under Bill de Blasio
that is not true Trump claimed that his
father gave him only a small loan in
1975 untrue 14 million dollars total
given to trump by his father over a
slightly longer period of time Donald
Trump said nobody was pressing birther
conspiracies before he was absolutely
untrue Trump denied saying that he would
ever negotiate the national debt or
attempt to that is not true and Trump
claimed that Isis has a lot of oil in
Libya no serious expert believes that
that is true that's just a sampling
that's around 10 or so of the lies that
Donald Trump told at the first debate
now I'm not going to ignore the fact
that Hillary Clinton also said things
that are not true a much shorter list
and you will find a list that requires
digging a little deeper in terms of our
definition definition of lie let's put
up the list now of Hillary Clinton's
misstatements there were only six and I
put them all up on the screen number one
Hillary Clinton denied calling the
trans-pacific partnership the gold
standard nor backing it before opposing
it she did do both of those things
Hillary Clinton claimed that the only
years of Donald Trump's tax returns that
we've seen show that he paid no federal
income tax that's not true there are
three years which show he paid taxes
during the nineteen seventies Hillary
Clinton claimed that Iran was weeks away
from having enough material for nuclear
weapons when she became secretary of
state that does not appear to be true
Hillary Clinton claimed that her tax
plan would not add a penny to the debt
that is not true it would add far less
to the debt than would Donald Trump's
tax plan only 200 billion versus five
trillion but Hillary Clinton's tax plan
would add to the debt line number five
from Hillary Clinton she said that
Donald Trump previously claimed women
don't deserve equal pay unless they do
as good a job as men it's sort of an
exaggeration I would say and lastly
Hillary Clinton claimed that Donald
Trump once publicly invited Vladimir
Putin to hack into Americans computers
this is an interpretation of something
that Donald Trump said so the great news
for people who took the UH under on
Donald Trump's lies the over-under was
at 38 and he since he only lied 34 times
that that actually made you some money
if you were on the under there here's
the thing for me what's fascinating is
what Donald Trump is choosing to lie
about it's stupid stuff that is easily
verified which demonstrates to me that
there is some at least somewhat of a
compulsive nature to these lies that we
are hearing from Donald Trump though the
quote lies from Hillary Clinton are
often issues over which there are some
disagreements from experts or their
complicated policy issues some some of
these would be a stretch to even say
that they are lies for example the paid
federal taxes thing right we're talking
about the nineteen seventies so yeah we
can say there are some years during the
seventies during which we know Trump
paid federal taxes but it may have been
decades since Trump it paid fair federal
taxes so not all lies created equal that
was my big takeaway from this I
understand your takeaway as well but i
guess the issue that i also have is that
this won't affect his supporters because
even when he lies they kind of think
that he's telling some larger truth
anyway and it was kind of disappointing
well not disappointing yeah
disappointing when i was heard that Rudy
Giuliani was saying oh but actually stop
and frisk what he said is right Lester
Holt is wrong it's completely
constitutional so that just doesn't make
sense to me because there's facts to
prove that he was wrong but it won't
affect his supporters no and maybe
that's why Pat I I know you wanted to
jump in on this maybe Trump is more okay
with saying things that are demonstrably
false because he knows it's not going to
affect the supporters after all he said
he could shoot people on Fifth Avenue no
one would care so it's amazing to me
that despite the fact we know that he
lies more and he out lied Hillary thirty
four to six in the first debate Trump
consistently pulls better on the issues
of honesty and trustworthiness then
Hillary does yet it's it is fascinating
and yet Rachel I want you seem very
eager to get in on this well I think
there's a reason for that I think people
are able to capitalize on this large
catastrophic issue with her emails that
happen so they can always default to
that and use it as kind of to construct
a larger narrative so to speak but with
Trump it's lie after lie after lie which
may even though they are big lies they
may seem smaller in comparison so I feel
like that could be a good reason for why
this is happening I think there's also
another element to this which is
sometimes simplicity no matter what form
it exists in is more appealing to voters
and even the issues on which Hillary
Clinton can appear less trustworthy are
far more complex issues and maybe in a
way she is being punished for that and
it is sort of uh Teflon Don has been the
nickname that some people apply to
Donald Trump in some ways that
everything including just dozens of lies
just fall off of him and there's
certainly something to that here
in debate number one by by at least one
count 34 26 Donald Trump he finally won
something in the debate he told way more
lies I've talked about how people of all
ages but particularly Millennials are
owning cars less and participating more
in the sharing economy and one of the
more popular options is zip car which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David